(upbeat music)
- So my experience that
I wanna share right now
because I feel like it's
gonna help me a lot to heal,
it's that when I was 16
I got pregnant from my first boyfriend,
we were in a serious relationship
and I didn't know anything
about life by the time.
And I ended up
not having the kid like I had an abortion
and coming where I come from
which is from South America,
it's a very bad situation.
Like I did the abortion myself at home.
Like I put some pills inside my body
and I started to have contractions.
It was pretty bad.
And I didn't have access
to like healthcare either
because of course they were
gonna like call my parents
and stuff and I didn't wanna do it.
So I just remained, you know,
in my room the whole time
like suffering, having constructions,
like I almost died.
Like I almost had a sepsis,
almost got infected.
And I feel like
that
taught me so many things by the time,
and right now I feel like
if I would go through the same situation
I would definitely keep the baby.
Of course, I feel bad for the baby,
but honestly I feel bad for women because
we are being judged no matter what,
like no matter what the
decision is, we're being judged
and I would definitely keep the baby.
And the lesson I wanna
keep from this story is like,
basically, it's your body and
you should do whatever you
feel more comfortable with.
I did it because my parents
were very strict with me
and I felt like I wouldn't
be able to go through
the whole process of
telling them I was pregnant
without being kicked out
of my house honestly.
Yeah, that's definitely,
that's gonna remain in my mind forever.
And I just wanted to
talk it all out today,
because I think that's
gonna help me heal a lot.
Thank you.
- So I'm a really open person.
I don't really have very many secrets,
but I guess a secret for myself is
I'm afraid of
not loving myself one day.
I'm afraid that I'll never learn that.
I'm not necessarily
insecure about how I look
or what I'm capable of ,
it's more of just
my heart is insecure.
So I want to be able to find that one day,
and I hope one day I'm
able to fully love myself
for who I am and to be
okay with being alone.
- All right.
My secret is that
I have had a crush
on one of my very close
friends for a very long time
and I don't know what to
do with that information.
Yup.
- [Interviewer] All right,
so you were the person
who just went, you said he
have a crush on your friend.
- I do.
- [Interviewer] And you're
willing to call them right now.
- I am willing to call her right now.
I'm just gonna be like,
I've been in to you
since like the first time I saw you
'cause you're incredibly
talented and beautiful.
Yeah, she's also sitting right there.
She came to visit me from Pennsylvania.
So yeah.
I'm so f***ing nervous.
Is it okay if I curse?
- That's fine.
- D**N.
(phone ringing)
- This is so chaotic.
- Hello.
- Hey like how are you?
(laughs loudly)
- Hey!
- None, that's it.
- I'm
Jinx.
- That, okay.
(laughs loudly)
Cute.
- Hey.
- Anyways, this is the person I called.
- [Interviewer] Did you have any idea
she was gonna call you?
- No, I didn't.
- Are you serious?
- I really didn't know.
I was asking...
I was like, is he gonna
be somebody from home?
And it was like, I don't think so.
And I was like...
- [Interviewer] How do you feel?
How do you feel?
- Kind of surprised.
- Why?
- Because I, well, you're like
a show stopping individual.
I never thought that you
would have a crush on me.
And I like had a crush
on for a very long time,
but I never said it.
(laughs loudly)
- Fact.
- Yeah.
I'm a pretty forward person.
- Yeah, this is the least
forward I've ever seen you.
'Cause like, if it has
been festering for a while
I'm surprised that it took you this long.
- Man, you're so intimidating.
- Seriously?
- Yeah.
- You're also very intimidating.
- Thank you.
Those are the final thoughts.
- Yeah.
- Good job.
- Thank you.
(slow paced music)
- Every time I meet a guy that I like,
I always like search up his address
and like look at his house and
like see if it's nice or not,
and like see how much it's worth.
So yeah.
(throat clearing)
- This is my secret.
So
my great uncle's
daughter's ex-husband
killed my great uncle
and the ex-husband has
been on the run ever since
and it's been like three years.
- My secret is that I was a
vegetarian only for the clout.
- I plan on moving away and telling nobody
every time someone's ever
tried to stop me I've listened.
I've decided I'm not gonna listen anymore.
and my funeral, because
they're the only two events
for the rest of my life,
where all of my family
and friends and loved ones
will be in the same
place at the same time.
I fantasize a lot about the music
and the playlist at these events
because music is a big part of my life,
and it makes me laugh
to think that I would
let my my mom be in
charge of my funeral music
'cause I just know that
she's gonna butcher that.
But the irony is I fantasize
a lot about my wedding day
and my funeral, but I will
only be at one of them.
- Hi.
I spent a month in a mental ward,
a string of a events from,
I want loco but for many reasons.
We can do a PBS documentary about it.
(laughs loudly)
I had a friend that passed
and
I couldn't focus on school and failed out
at UCLA my last quarter.
And so the only answer my parents thought
was like the mental ward.
Me. Kanye West, Metta World Peace,
all kicked in the same mental ward.
Wassup!
- I have a bacterial growth
in my armpits that caused them,
caused my hairs to turn neon orange.
- So my secret is that when I was younger,
I was at gymnastics camp
and we had a water day
where we played with
water balloons and stuff.
And so after the day almost
everyone was in the bathroom
like changing out of
their clothes and stuff.
And I was in the gym with my friend
and I was like, "I need
to go to the bathroom."
So I asked our coach if I
could go to the bathroom.
And she said no because
there were too many people
in the bathroom.
So I was like, okay, that's...
Okay.
And so then I started
walking along the floor
and I started peeing,
and then I jumped into the foam pit
because I had to pee
and I wanted to hide it.
And so I just jumped in the foam pit,
kept peeing and then somebody
ran by and stepped in it.
And then I told my friend, I said,
"You need to go tell the
coach that the floor is wet."
So my friend went up to
the coach and was like,
"The floor is wet with water."
And I said, "No, that's my pee."
And the coach was like,
"Go to the bathroom right now."
And I was like, "Fine,
you didn't even let me
go to the bathroom,
so of course I had to pee on your floor."
Like, I don't know.
And then later I was talking
to my friend and she was like,
"Why did you do that?"
And I was like, "Are you kidding me?
I had to pee."
And yeah, that's my secret.
- When I was 18 I went to
a sex club in New York City
and had
sex with a number of men,
and it turns out that
almost all of the men there were married.
And I only found out
because I saw
the man's phone screen and
it was his wife and kids.
- When I was in middle school,
I used to go to the local
high schools football games
and beat up kids my age.
I have no idea why I did it,
but eventually the police
started looking for me
and they never found me.
And looking back on this,
I'm incredibly disappointed in myself
and I can't imagine why I would
ever do something like that
in the first place.
It's just horrible.
- Trying to be happy
today, it's kind of hard
just because the family problems I have.
And I just wish that everyone
going through hard times
can stay strong.
If you have family problems
you're never alone.
- I've had three failed pregnancies.
- 12 years ago to the day
when I turned 17,
I attempted to commit suicide
but failed.
12 years later
I wonder if I will ever start
to feel that way again and
I'm just concerned that one day
I could get back to that dark place
and I just don't know what to do about it.
(gentle music)
- You thought I was gonna share a secret,
maybe next time.
Hi everyone.
I just wanna hop on here real quick
and give a shout out
and thank the 93 people
who signed up for my membership.
You'll see their names on the screen.
I recently decided to put
the join button on my channel
to help fund my projects in
new cities around the world
and to help fund the second camera woman
who's gonna capture the behind
the scenes for you guys.
So thank you for signing up.
You're truly helping make
that dream come true.
And thanks to all of you,
regardless of if you did
or didn't sign up,
because you've made so many of
my dreams come true already.
I love you guys, and
I'll see you next time.
(lighthearted guitar music)